I'm really interested in making people understand
about sanitation issues in the developing world.
And I think if I were to give a TED Talk,
I would focus on that,
on the 2.5 billion people
who don't have access to sanitation
and try to show solutions
and also how we should change
how we think about this problem
because it's really a big, big problem in the world.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.